how to start a consulting business so I
got a great question for my youtube
viewers love you guys
Raman who's finishing up University and
wants to start our consulting business
and I wrote in to ask me this mr.
Carmichael you can always call me Evan
after taking a consulting role
internship I found consultant in my
passion I'd like to start my own
consulting business but I don't have the
credibility or customer references that
help me get my first customer I believe
I have the knowledge to provide small
businesses with great advice but I need
the opportunity and trust from a small
business to get me started what is your
advice your videos are more inspiring
than my University business classes
happy face so thank you for that
compliment
here's the thing ok it's great that you
did this internship that you learned
about the business what I would
recommend you to do number one is go get
a job it's like what the entrepreneur
guy evan is telling me go get a job yeah
go get a job it's going to do a couple
things one it's going to it's going to
really tell you do you want to be a
consultant or not right so you found out
about consulting that this is your
passion to this internship so continue
on continue on and see if this is
something you want to continue rising
doing but also is going to give you
credibility and it's going to give you
experience okay you're going to get some
experience working from a consulting
business and you can see hopefully how
they built their business I wouldn't go
and work at a big consulting company I'd
work at a smaller one work at a company
that is you know ten people somebody you
respect look up to want to be like and
get involved in as many projects as you
can learn from the entrepreneur you
don't want to learn just how to be a
consultant you want to learn how to
build a business because there's so much
gold that goes into building a
consulting practice beyond just
providing the service to your clients so
go and get that experience and instead
of trying to do everything yourself here
you are you're getting paid and you're
getting paid to learn so you know I have
a zuga guide called work to learn that
goes through this step-by-step that can
guide you through the process it's a
great resource but it's so important to
go out and do this because I don't want
you to go out try to launch your
business not get any customers and then
have to go back and get some kind of job
right it's better to get the job learn
you're getting the job for the whole
purpose to learn not just to make money
you're not just getting some job because
it's high pain you're getting to learn
about the business and again that
smaller company ten employees where you
can connect with the entrepreneur
founder and learn about how they built
the business get involved in as many
things as possible to learn so when you
go and you launch your own company full
time you can hit the ground running the
second thing I would do is start part
time so start your own business on the
side part time it's okay you don't have
to jump in full time at a university
start part time so you're working at a
consulting gig you're learning
everything you need to learn you're
building up experience you're building
up credibility building up contact the
same time start on the side part time
let me even be taking on a few small
business clients for free just to get
them started but you're starting part
time too to get the experience and
practice of how to find clients of
working with them of it being your own
brand your own name but it's not like
everything is hinging on this being
successful because you still have your
job that's paying you money that you're
learning from you may even discover that
small businesses in the right market for
you it's really hard to be successful as
a consultant selling the small
businesses because they don't have money
right entrepreneurs don't have money we
always need money so it's hard to get
what you're worth as a consultant
selling to entrepreneurs you're probably
looking at people who are a little bit
more established otherwise you're doing
things for free right like I don't have
a consulting business instead I do
videos and I do things on a more mass
scale because I can either sell
advertising or corporate partnerships
and sponsorships because it's too hard
to get money out of small business
owners so something to think about but
start part time you'll discover what
your market is you'll discover how to
sell but it's not totally dependent on
you going out and doing that full time
for your business third thing is watch
more videos so if you've gotten a lot of
inspirations from my videos that's great
thank you so much watch more like you
can watch mine but also watch other
people if you're learning when I get on
these videos most of them are are
answering people's questions right this
is the stuff
you are going to have to do answer
entrepreneurial questions so you can
learn through osmosis you can learn from
watching my videos and learning from the
experiences that I'm going through
sharing my stories and all the
entrepreneur's right in you're learning
from their stories and other people too
if there's other entrepreneur people who
you like on YouTube who have a great
message watch them as well you're going
to learn and gain more if you find that
more helpful and useful than your
university classes which I would
probably happen to agree with myself
then keep doing that because that's part
of your education something that you
love doing something you love watching
that's going to help build you up and
something that I say or something that
somebody else might say may prove to be
really relevant to one of your clients
and you know what if you build a
relationship so you know me now a little
bit if you start working with a client
and it may not be for a lot of money may
even be free you can even write in like
you can ask me how would I solve this
problem or ask other people how would
they solve that problem and so you're
building off the experience of all these
other people too that you can bring back
to your client so hopefully that helps
thank you so much for the great comment
and for your viewership and watching all
the videos I really appreciate it for
those of you guys watching thumbs up
below if you liked it leave a question
leave a comment I can make a video
response for you just like I did on this
one and if you want to see more videos
like this you can click on my face to
subscribe thank you so much and I'll see
you soon
you